did you see her Halloween costume yes
and like the rest of the nation I'm not
sure how I feel about you you can't stop
looking at it but you're really not sure
so weird but I was so into
intrusive and three days did it right
she definitely did she always does and
three days after she wormed her way to
the top of the Hollywood Costume chain
Heidi told our Wilmar Fuji her favorite
moment of the night was courtesy of E.T
E.T you guys probably have the funniest
photo when I'm laying on the floor and I
have the ET mic right in front of me
that's probably one of my most favorite
shots of all it's iconic you know what
they say the early bird catches the worm
it just literally makes me like smile so
much because you see this weirdness of a
worm but then you still see my like
cheesy smile in the middle of it it was
strange to be in there I have to say
because no one can really hear you you
can't really hear anyone because it's
like this everything is muffled at all
times I just said to my husband please
don't leave me flat on my face and
suffocate because I was worried that I
forget about me I don't know last night
Heidi was back to her sizzling
supermodel ways alongside Terry Crews
Simon Cowell and Howie Mandel to promote
the next season of NBC's AGT All-Stars
what was your reaction when you saw her
dressed as this worm it was scary
I've said to Heidi you're super mom you
could look good in anything and then she
just proved me wrong I wasn't attracted
to the worm were you like hyped when
you're like putting your costume you're
like I look great as Mr T and then you
see Heidi well you know I was like I won
Halloween whoops no I didn't
[Music]